Russia has Unleashed a barrage of
missiles striking multiple targets
across Ukraine for the first time in two
weeks at least 20 people have been
killed in the Central City of danipra
where Rockets hit two residential
buildings that's according to the
governor at least 60 were reported
injured rescue teams are searching for
survivors in the rubble
strikes were also reported in Kiev and
the Western city of leviv one rocket
left a huge crater in a village near the
capital the missile attacks hit power
infrastructure resulting in major
blackouts across the country
Natasha Butler joins us now live from
kieva it's uh it's morning there is the
scale of Destruction from the overnight
attacks becoming clearer
well it is indeed and you know every
minute every hour really counts as
rescue teams continue to sift through
the rubble uh underneath that apartment
block and denipro that was hit by a
Russian missile on Saturday uh destroyed
pretty much I mean we saw it a a flame
now what they say is that they've
managed to pull out dozens of people
alive including a three-year-old girl
but sadly we know now that local
officials are saying at least 20 people
have been killed including a teenage
girl so very sad and Grim scenes there
indeed it's particularly difficult work
for The Rescuers because they're having
to work in very cold conditions often
without enough electricity or in the
night enough light because of the
ongoing power shortages now the attack
in dinipo was part though of a wider
picture there was a wave of missile
attacks across Ukraine or Saturday
including here in the capital Kiev we
certainly heard a series series of
explosions and those attacks were mainly
targeting infrastructure power
infrastructure that's according to
Ukrainian officials who say that a
number of facilities were hit they of
course will be now looking to try and
repair those facilities restore some of
the power and electricity but it's going
to take time so what they're saying is
that they are putting in place a number
of emergency outages over the next few
weeks but they say look many people
across Ukraine will be facing in terms
of electricity and power a very
difficult few days ahead
and we've also been hearing those
reports about Western countries will
start sending tanks are we getting any
kind of reaction or comment from
Ukrainian officials from the Ukrainian
president on that
well the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zlinski in his nightly address uh he
talked about denipro he paid tribute to
the people who are working so hard to
rescue people and said everything will
be done to rescue every last person
every Survivor possible and he said look
this is just another example of what he
called Russian terrorism and the way to
stop these kind of attacks he says is by
sending more weapons now we know that
Britain has confirmed that it will send
some of its Challenger to tank zelenski
has welcomed that and he's certainly
going to hope that that paves the way
for other Western powers to also send uh
tanks we know for example that countries
like Poland are willing to send their
german-built leopard tanks but that has
to be signed off by Germany Germany so
far has been quite reluctant to sign off
on European power sending uh their
german-built tanks because they're
worried that that's going to send the
wrong sign to Moscow that it's going to
escalate the conflict but there's
certainly more and more pressure
building the fact that the UK has
decided to send these tanks we'll
certainly see other Western Powers
following suit in the next days
all right thanks so much Natasha Butler